and today could be a pivotal day in the
prosecutions of those arrested in the
aftermath of the January 6th attack on
the capitol the trial of accused
ringleaders from the far-right group
proud boys is heading to a jury one
lawyer for the proud boy says blame for
the attack lies squarely not with them
but with Donald Trump Scott McFarland is
at the federal courthouse in Washington
Forest Scott good morning
Tony this is the longest U.S Capitol
Insurrection trial today jurors have sat
through four months of arguments and of
testimony the five defendants are
members of the far right proud boys
group and they face the highest level
charge so far seditious conspiracy
accused of plotting to block the
peaceful transfer of power in America
and some of them of leading the mob ask
the police and into the capitol the
group includes Enrique tario whose
defense attorney told the jurors
yesterday it was Donald Trump's words
his motivations his anger that caused
what occurred on January 6th if
convicted tario would be the only person
so far convicted of conspiracy for
January 6 who wasn't actually at the
Capitol that day accused of helping lead
the conspiracy from afar as of this
morning there are 1 000 plus defendants
in the U.S Capitol attack roughly half
of those cases have closed but every
defendant to face a jury has been at
least partially convicted and hundreds
more arrests are still expected Gail
be interesting to see how this turns out
thank you Scott